il ya un exemple et c'est un bon joueur
de hockey du nouveau brunswick sur la
glace les but qu'il marque change le
cours d'un match
maintenant c'est le sport qu'ils
aimeraient changer yannick est
homosexuel trois petits mots simples à
premier abord mais qui sont lourds de
sens quand on joue au hockey à d'abord
atteint grosse affaire comme cesser de
faire du changement dans deux entrevues
sur le web dont l'une à radio canada il
dévoile publiquement son homosexualité
pour s'affirmer et surtout pour inspirer
en grandissant je connais ça pas de joie
chi des drainages ou qui joua au niveau
qu'était thermos sexuelle
je pense que ce qui est joli et ça je
pense à mourad et beaucoup c'est que
cette femme pour les jeunes son histoire
fait grand bruit car yannick duplessis
un joueur de hockey élite dans la
province et un choix de neuvième tour
des voltigeurs de drummondville dans la
ligue de hockey junior majeur du québec
habituellement les joueurs comme lui ne
parle pas d'homosexualité
il a longtemps refoulée ses émotions
tues tu joues à noro qui est pour toi
d'inde de f1 c'est pas mal l'attentât
près en tapant super bien joué puis ça
vient que tu joues stars hollow toujours
au pire tu peux pas être à la fois de
plus dur c'est accepter les petites
choses simples deviennent complexes
comme prendre une douche dans le
vestiaire la part de faire juger comme
après que sa requête alors quand j'avais
par la baule et douches people c'était
moi moi ça je voulais pas que les
joueurs pensent que j'étais à l'opéra
pour les gardes des pierres c'est déjà
des commentaires que j'ai déjà entendu
avant yannick c'est d'abord ouvert à ses
parents qui ont compris bien des choses
tu es comme un choc bon je savais qu'il
y avait quelque chose avec diane et à
l'époque c'était pas yannick on a bear
abondent
maintenant il y en a qui s'est libéré
d'un poids sur les épaules il reçoit des
messages d'encouragement il était dans
un placard et c'est lui qui a ouvert la
porte pour en parler c'est juste mon
bestiaire l'indifférence vis
tu as bien commencé depuis hier
l'ampleur
bon on garde pire on est vraiment proche
de lui ses parents sont fiers de sa
démarche qui aurait pu être risqué bon
on pensait tout temps au pire que kilian
est caché par éjecter piscine est rompu
yannick va jouer ou à pied cet automne
avec son école secondaire
par la suite il verra un match à la fois
comme on dit wak est ici françois
leblanc ray du canada à saint-antoine